yes I sunk to this level let me sort of
apologize in advance to some of my
friends in comparative religion but let
me explain about 10 years ago I uploaded
to my private channel a video where I
listed my top 10 favourite movies of all
time
that video is now private but before I
turn it private it managed to get more
than 60,000 views clearly then stupid
top 10 lists is the only way to get any
views on this platform and after all
views on YouTube is the key to happiness
so screw it
here is your stupid top 10 list today I
will list the top 10 most popular
religions in the world that is the
biggest religions with the most number
of adherents I hope you didn't think
this video was gonna be about the top 10
best religions in the world because
there would be absolutely ridiculous
because everything in this video is very
problematic and highly you simplified I
should clarify a few things firstly it
is very very difficult to know exactly
how many people follow a specific
religious tradition and the methodology
used by a lot of these research groups
is heavily flawed there is also the
question of what actually constitutes a
religion is confusion ism a religion for
example and what makes a person a
confusion mist is that the word
confusion is when is a person officially
a follower of a religion for example
Japan is a country that is often viewed
as highly atheistic that people are
atheist and yet a lot of people still
visit the old Shinto shrines and perform
rituals according to these Shinto
traditions so then our Japanese people
mainly atheist or are they Shinto
furthermore the relationship between
Buddhism and Shintoism in Japan is
highly problematic and they've sort of
emerged in a lot of ways and people
sometimes go to Shinto shrines but they
also do Buddhist rituals and so then are
they Buddhists or are they Shinto very
difficult questions to answer and that
also has of course an effect on research
such as this and on videos where people
try to list the top 10 most popular
religions these are just a few of the
problems that we run into when we talk
about subjects like this and so anything
that I say
this video should of course be taken
with a huge grain of salt nonetheless
for this video I have chosen to
primarily follow the research by Pew
Research Center that they published back
in 2015 with a few notifications for
example I have removed some very
ambiguous categories like one called
other religions and instead replaced
them with some of the traditions that
were included in that category and sort
of ranked them according to information
about the amount of followers from other
sources as well so what we should have
here is at least a pretty accurate list
of the the biggest religions in the
world number 10
Jainism Jainism is a religious
traditions with origins in India its
followers believe that it has existed
forever but the historians suggest that
it may have originated sometime around
800 BCE ish being an ancient Indian
religion it shares a lot of similarities
with other religions from this region
such as Hinduism and Buddhism and have a
lot of the same concepts and aesthetics
like reincarnation and samsara karma as
well as the the sort of ohms symbol the
ohm sound but in spite of this Jainism
is very much its own distinct tradition
when talking about Jainism one often
brings up three very important concepts
the first is ahimsa or non-violence
jane's are famous for its emphasis on
extreme non-violence towards all things
in the world there are stories of Jane's
to know when they walk barefoot but also
gently brush the ground before them in
order to not hurt any any sort of
animals small animals walking on the
ground there are also examples of Jane's
who were covers over the mouth in order
to not swallow or hurt any insects that
might be flying around in front of them
the second religious concept is
anekantavada or many sidedness this is a
rather complex subject but it deals with
the complexity of the world the world is
of course a very complex place and
reality can't be explained in language
so naturally there will be a lot of
different views and perspectives on
things and this is an important
teaching within Jainism the third
concept is aparigraha or non-attachment
similar to a lot of other religious
traditions especially from this region
there is a large emphasis on
non-attachment and also asceticism forms
of sometimes extreme asceticism Jainism
in fact from all these traditions is
perhaps and I'm generalizing a bit here
the one religion where the more extreme
forms of asceticism is most prominent
there are about four point two million
gains in the world today making it zero
point oh six percent of the world's
population number nine the Baha'i faith
with origins in the late 19th century
the Baha'i faith is the ninth most
populous in the world with around seven
million people or a zero point ten
percent of the world's population it was
founded in what is today Iran by a man
named Baha'u'llah who was considered by
the Baha'is to be a prophet in fact
according to Baha'i faith
b'hala is the latest in a long line of
prophets that includes the Buddha Jesus
as well as Muhammad often mentioned as
the main tenant of the Baha'i faith is
something known as the unity of
religions which is a statement that all
religions from history are valid and
have been sort of different
dispensations of the ultimate truth the
Baha'is being the sort of latest and
most complete of these this is pretty
similar to similar ideas expressed by by
Islam with the exception that the Baha'i
faith also includes were extends that
sort of validity of religions beyond the
Abrahamic framework by including
prophets like the Buddha and some others
from other traditions like Hinduism or
Sikhism and so on
another main tenant is the unity of
humanity which states that all humans
are created equal and thus the Baha'i
faith at least ideally rejects any
concepts like racism nationalism castes
or anything that would sort of
compromise that unity of humanity the
Baha'i faith does have certain origins
in Islam at least coming out of that
region and that culture especially the
Shia oriented Islam that was prominent
in Iran
the time of this religion since Epson
but it is of course it's own religion
its own tradition and have in fact been
very much persecuted and an oppressed by
by the Iranian regime since its
inception nonetheless it remains pretty
strong in this region as well as in
other countries like the United States
the very famous actor Rainn Wilson from
the office is a member of this community
for example number eights Judaism at
number eight
perhaps surprising to some of you we
have Judaism the earliest of the three
large Abrahamic religions is also the
smallest with around 14 million people
and 0.20 percent of the world's
population Judaism doesn't need much
introduction for most of you the story
goes that the Israelites were slaves in
Egypt and that then escaped with the
help of the prophet Moses who then
received Commandments from God on Mount
Sinai
now this supposedly happened around a
thousand years BCE the main point being
made by Judaism and his theology and one
that was pretty original at the time was
that there was only one supreme god
known as yah sometimes also elohim
Judaism is consider often to be the
first monotheistic religion which is not
necessarily true maybe if we consider
other movements that have appeared
before that but nonetheless it was very
much a pioneer for this kind of theology
the most sacred scripture for the Jews
is of course the Hebrew Bible or the
Tanakh and the Torah which is the first
part of the Tanakh which is the highest
of those texts the Hebrew Bible is
what's known as the Old Testament to
Christians and in the Christian Bible
there is this idea in Judaism of being
God's chosen people and that the Land of
Israel is their sort of God given home
Judaism is still a very vibrant religion
today with a long and complex history
and it is also significant because it is
the basis from which both Christianity
and Islam would later arise number seven
Sikhism one of the younger religions on
this list sikhism appears in India in
the 15th and 16th centuries its
foundations are based on the teachings
of a few so-called gurus teachers that
appeared at this time the most
significant and prominent of these is
the first guru known as Guru Nanak
Sikhism can be categorized as a
monotheistic religion with a belief in
one God that is both present and
transcendent some of the practices
include meditation on God's name as well
as singing or reading hymns from the
Sacred Scripture known as the Guru
Granth Sahib very characteristically
most Sikh men wear a turban which has a
basis in the establishment of the Hansa
community by the 10th and last Guru Guru
Gobind Singh when establishing this
community there was a new code of
conduct which included what is known as
the five K's number one cache or long
unkept hair thus the turban signifying
one's connection to the laws of nature
number two is kanga a comb to keep the
hair clean which also symbolizes a
rejection of asceticism and affirms
one's role as a householder number three
skip on a dagger a short sword
signifying the right to bear arms and
once duty to protect life number 4 cada
an iron bracelet to serve as a reminder
once mortality and lastly number five is
the cash certain undergarments to
emphasize sexual restraint gurus of
early Sikhism lived between the 15th and
the 18th century the first of these Guru
Nanak is thought to have taught that
there is no Muslim and there is no Hindu
seemingly signifying a kind of unity of
humanity sort of in spite of creed or
religion as mentioned above the Guru's
also emphasized attachment but did not
encourage anyone to live aesthetically
in fact every important aspect of seek
teaching is that one is to be a
householder and to to be a member of
society the line of guru start with guru
nanak and ends with Guru Gobind Singh
who formed the hollister community that
I mentioned and ended the official sort
of human line of
gurus instead from then on there are no
more human gurus but instead one eternal
guru which is the sacred scripture of
Sikhism known as the Guru Granth Sahib
now this is a text that contains hymns
and poems by some of the Guru's as well
as individuals from other religious
traditions such as some some Hindus as
well as Sufi Muslims it's not uncommon
to hear people say that Sikhism is like
a mix between Hinduism and Islam and
this is of course a huge
oversimplification but it is true that
Sikhism of course arose out of our
cultural context where Hinduism and
particularly Sufi oriented Islam was
very prominent in India in the 15th and
16th centuries and so of course it
contains elements from both of these but
one should not forget that it also is
very much a distinct and its own
religion during the last few centuries
since its inception
Sikhism has grown impressively fast
becoming the seventh largest religion
according to this research with 30
million followers and 0.32 percent of
the world's population number 6 Falk
religions and that number 6 we have one
of those very ambiguous categories you
may wonder what Falk religions actually
mean and so did I so I decided to look
it up on their website or on their sort
of methodology methodology section what
they mean by this term and this is what
it says folk religions are closely tied
to a particular people ethnicity or
tribe in some cases elements of other
world religions are blended with local
beliefs and customs these faiths have no
formal Creed's or sacred texts examples
of folk religions include African
traditional religions Chinese folk
religions Native American religions and
Australian Aboriginal religions in other
words this is a category that includes a
lot of smaller traditions from around
the world I would have perhaps like a
more clear explanation of what these
actually are
for example in terms of Chinese folk
religions I thought does this include
Taoism for example but then I realized
it didn't because Taoism was included in
another ambiguous kateri called other
religions that I removed from this video
so it's not entirely clear exactly what
they mean here in any case these folk
religions put together are pretty
popular because they make up about 400
million people or 5.7 percent of the
world's population as you can tell the
numbers are getting higher and we are
now entering into the top 5 number 5
Buddhism yes it's your aunt's favorite
religion Buddhism and all religions
centered around the teachings of a man
called Siddhartha Gautama or also known
later as the Buddha who was a prince
from India or actually from Nepal where
a state like Nepal who turns into a
spiritual teacher after he got a glimpse
of the suffering in the world in
Buddhist teachings there exists the idea
of the Four Noble Truths the first of
which is the fact that all life is
suffering the other three having to do
with the truth of the origin of
suffering that suffering can end and
that the way to end suffering is to
follow the so called Eightfold Path
aside from the fact that all life is
suffering some of the main philosophical
tenets of Buddhism include an idea that
everything in existence is in constant
change and a nuts Hmong
the idea that the self is illusory and
doesn't exist again Buddhism shares a
lot of similarities and concepts with
its brother and sister religions from
this region in India like samsara and
karma and liberation the ultimate sort
of goal for a Buddhist is to reach a
state known as Nirvana where the life or
the suffering of life is completely
transcendent being so long ago it's
difficult to know exactly when Buddhism
appeared or when the Buddha lived but
some scholars and people believed that
he lived around the 4th century BCE
Buddhism is divided into a number of
branches including tera vaada Buddhism
dominating in places like Thailand India
and Cambodia as well as Mahayana
Buddhism existing primarily in China
and Korea and Vietnam both of these
differ from each other in numerous ways
some believe in no gods or deities and
all while others do and so on
Buddhism is one of the largest religions
in the world obviously as evidenced from
the placement on this list with around
500 million followers or 6.9 percent of
the world's population number for
Hinduism another Indian religion and one
that in a lot of ways has been around
for a very long time what's interesting
about Hinduism is that it's not really a
religion at all and I don't mean that in
these sort of it's actually a
spirituality way or whatever but it's
actually Hinduism is actually kind of an
umbrella term for a whole bunch of
different traditions and religions that
exists and existed historically within
the Indian subcontinent the word Hindu
Hindu is a word that has been used
mainly by occupying forces first the
Muslims and then the Christians so
basically any religious tradition that
existed in India however different was
deemed Hindu by the fact that they were
not Muslim or Christians however what
happened is that the Hindus themselves
then sort of hijacked that term and
started using it themselves and used it
to their advantage and so it eventually
became a term that they themselves used
and became a sort of source of pride and
identity so in a sense you could say
that a Hinduism does exist today because
the people where the Hindus themselves
have made it their own and it only
really becomes problematic when we talk
about it historically Hindus believe in
worship many deities like Vishnu and
Shiva and Ganesh and so on there is also
a concept especially within the Vedanta
tradition of this supreme God called the
Brahm Han from which all the other
deities only stem and so it seemed so
you know it's usually categorized as a
polytheistic religion there are many
deities but there's also the Brahmin
which is a concept similar to the
monotheistic God of the Abrahamic
religions so you can view it in many
different ways
Hindus believe in the concept Dharma
which is impossible to chance
but it's the kind of divine order of the
world where things like the
controversial caste system is included
for example there are sacred scriptures
and Hinduism particularly the Vedas and
also the epic Mahabharata of which the
Bhagavad Gita is a chapter central to
Hinduism like so many other Indian
religions are concepts like samsara and
reincarnation and karma the ultimate
goal for a Hindu is to reach liberation
known as moksha which is to be freed
from the cycle of of life and death and
reincarnation forever there are a lot of
Hindus in the world guys the number at
around 1.1 billion people or 15 point
one percent of the world's population
number three unaffiliated or nuns
another perhaps surprising to some of
you at number three we have the category
unaffiliated or also known as nuns this
is a rather broad category that includes
atheists agnostics as well as Swedish
people who say that they are spiritual
but not religious basically it's anyone
who sort of doesn't belong to a specific
religious institution be they atheists
or that they believe in a God but don't
sort of adhere to a specific
institutionalized religious tradition
there's a lot of people who find
themselves in this category today in
fact according to Pew Research Center
they number at 1.2 billion people or 16
percent of the world's population not
really much to say here it's a religious
group that is definitely on the rise we
can see that religious beliefs are in no
increasing around the world but that
adherence to the large institutions are
in some ways I talked about this some in
a previous video called what is religion
so if you want to check that out it's
available in the description number two
Islam now we're getting into the
category where the answers are pretty
obvious Islam is the second largest
religion in the world and the
fastest-growing one it is a strictly
monotheistic faith with origins in 7th
century Arabia where the Prophet
Muhammad preached that there is only one
God which is the God of the Jews and the
Christians by the way and that he was
the mess
of this god he was violently opposed by
the the rulers in Mecca and was forced
to leave and establish a new community
in a city that later became known as
Medina and after his death his followers
and his successors managed to conquer
large parts of the Middle East and North
Africa all the way to Spain and all the
way to Western China which helped of
course spread the teachings of this
religion and also helped it become the
sort of second largest religion that it
is today
like all religions Islam is a very large
and complex one with multiple branches
schools of thought and philosophies but
they all sort of have in common this one
concept that is expressed in the
proclamation of faith also known as the
Shahada which is there is no god but God
and Muhammad is God's messenger also
important is the so-called five pillars
of Islam the first of which is the
Shahada that I just mentioned there is
also the daily prayers that are
performed five times a day
there is the pilgrimage to the city
Mecca known as the Hajj that is to be
performed at least once in a lifetime
there is giving charity to the poor as
well as fasting during the month of
Ramadan Muslims can be found all over
the world today the number at 1.8
billion people worldwide and twenty four
point one percent of the world's
population number one Christianity
Christianity remains the largest
religion in the world with 2.3 billion
followers and 30 1.2 percent of the
world's population centered around the
Jewish preacher Jesus from first century
Palestine who is later executed by the
Roman officials by crucifixion
mainstream Christian theology considered
Jesus to be God made into flesh
sometimes also known as the Son of God
or the Word of God it is believed that
God took this human form as the Son and
sacrificed him out of love for Humanity
and to atone for all their sins anyone
can reach eternal life and salvation
if they believe in Jesus and follow his
word Christian theology also includes
what is known as the Trinity which is
that God is one but is expressed in
three persons that is the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit the spread of the
young Christian religion was helped by
preachers like Paul who introduced it to
the greek-speaking world and perhaps
most importantly to Rome Christianity's
status as a world religion was sealed in
the fourth century when the emperor
constantine made it the official
religion of the Empire the sayings and
life of Jesus are gathered in the
Gospels of Luke Matthew Mark and John
which make up together with a lot of
other texts what is known that'sthat's
the New Testament and the Bible as it is
known in Christianity consists of this
New Testament as well as the Old
Testament which is what the Hebrews are
the Jews known as the Hebrew Bible or
the Tanakh common practices of
Christianity are of course very familiar
to us in the West and include church
service on Sundays and the Eucharist
where bread and wine is symbolically or
otherwise turn into the body and blood
of Christ and then consumed every year
at Easter the death and resurrection of
Jesus is celebrated as well as its birth
on Christmas as with all the religions
mentioned on this list Christianity is a
very large religion it is a very complex
religion that is divided into many sects
and denominations and there are too many
of them for me to name them right now
what I can say is that there is usually
three main subgroups that one divides
Christianity into and that includes the
Roman Catholic Church the Orthodox
churches and different versions of
Protestantism these groups can differ
significantly in doctrine and practice
even if they have in common the Sacred
Scripture as well as certain aspect of
theology and the early stories of
Christianity I could of course talk
about these religions all day but all
things must come to an end as they say
so there you go
that's the top 10 list of the biggest
religions in the world
what did you think of this list did any
of the results surprise you or do you
even downright disagree with something
let me know in the comments and I will
see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]